nos piden que movamos el punto
anaranjado al número que es igual a 7
por un sexto bien puedes tener 7 por un
sexto es pensar que vamos a mover este
punto anaranjado al lugar en donde estas
siete veces un sexto así que empecemos
vamos a moverla una vez un sexto o esto
es lo mismo que uno por un sexto por acá
son dos veces un sexto que es lo mismo
que dos sextos por acá tengo tres veces
un sexto que es lo mismo que tres por un
sexto porque tengo cuatro veces un sexto
que es lo mismo que cuatro por un sexto
cinco veces un sexto seis veces un sexto
y por acá tengo siete veces un sexto que
es lo mismo que siete por un sexto siete
por un sexto va a ser lo mismo que siete
sextos o lo que es lo mismo siete veces
un sexto
espero que todo esto tenga sentido para
ti vamos a comprobar la respuesta y muy
bien vamos a hacer otro más ahora tengo
este de aquí mueve el punto anaranjado
al número que es igual a 2 por 5 medios
bueno pues una vez 5 medios eso nos va a
dar bueno pues 5 medios y si queremos
otra vez 5 medios lo que tenemos que
hacer es agregarle 5 medios a esto que
tenemos por lo tanto nos vamos a mover
de nuevo 5 medios a la derecha y
entonces 5 medios más 5 medios nos van a
dar 10 medios así que una vez 5 medios
nos da 5 medios y 2 veces 5 medios nos
da 10 medios y observa esto es lo mismo
que 2 por 5 que es 10 entre 2 10 medios
muy bien vamos a comprobar la respuesta
y vamos a hacer uno más esta vez tengo
mueve el punto naranja done al número
que es igual a tres por tres medios
bueno pues empezamos en cero medios lo
cual es cero lo puedes ver como cero
veces tres medios y después si nos vamos
a una vez tres medios eso nos va a
llevar a tres medios y si después nos
tomamos dos veces tres medios bueno va a
ser lo mismo que sumar otra vez tres
medios y vamos a llegar a seis medios y
si queremos tres veces tres medios
entonces habrá que sumar otra vez tres
medios y vamos a llegar a nueve medios y
ya está
comprobamos respuesta y lo hemos logrado